[Music]
why did you learn how to fly a
helicopter I mean how will that benefit
you if you don't own a helicopter do you
want to do a side job as a helicopter
pilot
I thought fires wildfires well what was
that yeah I was getting really into
conspiracy theory right around 2008 with
the banks going down and nobody [ __ ]
doing anything to them right but just
the chaos that was going to happen
cities and I was living in the middle of
LA and which is unbelievably
claustrophobic it takes like two and a
half hours to get out of even when it
works right
forget about if society was collapsing
so I was thinking how the [ __ ] do I get
out of here and the only way out was up
and out with the helicopter so it took
me a number of years you mean you were
so [ __ ] freaked out and so bought
into like this is it
you took it one step further you said
I'm gonna learn how to fly a helicopter
so I can helicopter out of LA up and
down the [ __ ] hits in a two seater that
only has enough room for me and my wife
and maybe a couple containers of apple
sauce and that and then the big thing is
where are you going well that's that's
my next question how do you get to the
helicopter I didn't think it out I just
really thought of how much a helicopter
no you get to the helicopter where are
you going I don't know where I was going
I was just you know when the zombies
were coming up the street I was just
going to [ __ ] it I was going to stay up
in a hover until they ate everybody and
they were full and I was going to land
on like a Ralph's or something and run
in and grab some hands and they get out
of this